is your honor for the choir director  over at green valley high school kim  ritzer is a semi-finalist  for the 2021 grammy music educate  educator award  she is one of 25 teachers to get to that  point  there were nearly 2 000 submissions the  award recognizes teachers making a  lasting contribution to music education  ritzer has taught music here in southern  nevada for 31 years  she's shown thousands of students how to  find their voice and use it to make the  world a better place  hard work kindness bravery and  enthusiasm are just a few of the  qualities  which mrs ritzer exudes on a daily basis  and helps to instill in all of us  her students have performed all around  the country they sang at carnegie hall  and with the rolling stones ten  finalists for the award will be named  next month congratulations kim that is  so great nate